each of you has been selected because
you're the best in your field
oh that we could find Oh your skills
will be put to the test facing this as
you can clearly see this is a volcano
volcano is what my assistant was going
to say system actually it's a composite
volcano you can tell by the height and
the clearly apparent bed clusters okay
forget I said volcano this is a it's a
super weapon Oh weird as it looks just
like a volcano yep and here's the scary
part
this is their psychotic leader oh how
they get there or me I mean you took up
em this is they're psychotic leader
ah whoa hey buddy do you know her
what me no no definitely not absolutely
not never seen her before in my life who
is that I don't know not terribly
convincing hey it's me red you know the
guy everybody hated who kind of saved
the whole island anyway war with Leonard
in the pigs what are you gonna do I'm a
foodie still going on those what and BOM
and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt and me well
I still have some anger issues but I'm
finding healthier ways to deal with it
Fred I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island one good reason why I
should believe you now show you the
proof will deem very really but this is
a hundred times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver we just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing we're gonna break in the
weapon was amazing we gotta get that key
card hello fellow Eagle God how he's
doing a voice yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]